Năng Mỹ trên khai lực gượng nhằm kìm xuất đảo khóng, chúng tâm xuất thậu dổ mỏ quan trọng
của Iran đang thú hút dự chú ý trong bất cảnh xuống độ giá trang theo BBC có khoảng
chiếm viên phần trăm lượng dổ xuất thậu của Iran được chung chuyển quan hòn đau này.
Huyên Khó trở thành một tiêu chiến lượng, nếu Washington muốn gây xa cách kính tế lên
Tây Iran nhằm cách sản muốn thu dổ dổ mỏ của Iran, giá tăng xác để khơi thông
nhờ biển thông ớt, giá phần thích cho giá Mỹ có thể chiến khai các phương án độ bộ đường
không hoặc đường miệng. Để kìm xuất đảo trong thời gian, lượng Mỹ hiện diện gồm gần
nâm nghiên lính tuổi đánh bộ và khoảng 2 nghỉ lixo thú dựa, thú dựa
thú dựa năng tham 2, tuy nhiên về tiếp cận khu vực này gặp nhiều thích thức
thì Iran đã tăng cường hệ thống phòng thủ, bác hồn tên lượng và tiếp hiệm bay không
hề lái tại khu vực đảo khó. Fíi râm cạnh báo sẽ đáp trả mạnh mấy nếu bị tân công
đồng thời cá mục Mỹ về đi xuất đảm phán vừa ra tăng hiện diện quân sự.